next up we've got dot notation for
objects which we just use to access bio
dot name dot notation allows us to
declare an object and then define its
properties outside the curly braces the
syntax looks like so we'll have object
dot some property equals some value for
instance bio that email equals my email
address hey I see we didn't use var nope
well that notation there's no need to
use var we're adding properties to an
object not creating new variables right
and then we'll access them the same way
we did before yep we can use dot
notation to access properties and append
them to the page there's at least one
more syntax pattern to define the
properties of an object right yeah
bracket notation there's actually one
more but to learn more about that when
you can check out the instructors notes
bracket notation is similar to dot
notation in that we can declare an
object and then later in the code define
its properties this time rather than
dots
we'll use brackets so we have bio with
the string city in brackets equals
Mountainview
and bio with the string email in
brackets equals my email address right
so the syntax looks like object then a
string of the property name inside these
square brackets equals some value yeah
so if we wanted to append our city to
the page we've just write this code
right here and when we refresh our page
we see that it still says Mountain View